juve mixer a leggere ed harris the best
[Musica]
anyway quattro piccoli guardava hannah
montana spero che alcuni abbiano smesso
di fare questa cosa e che iniziano a
guardare qualcosa di più istruttivo tipo
fa vj
ecco in questo caso per il pubblico
piccolo che sta guardando voi da grandi
canterete io che cantano lontana si
spera di dio bella tutti ragazzi valori
che mi sono vicine sono falli genova di
600 flores ragazzi mancavano solo le
ultime due torri cominciamo piano 1
sorta siamo sul christmas edition la
dote eravamo ad halloween edition penso
di esserne in grado poi magari no però è
un po presto per natale va bene allora
let's go amici mi devo far vedere che
qualcosa vago in questo gioco ma porta e
cliccare a calcio cosa che sa fare molto
bene perché questa è roba sì perché
cambiano tutti insieme what se sta roba
aiuto perché cambiano tutti insieme beh
allora proviamo ad inserire la data di
natale quindi 25 dicembre
solo che siamo in america quindi devi
mettere prima jorn poi la prima al mese
quel giorno quindi 12 25
se funziona me ne vado veramente a fare
sherlock poi magari non funziona e
quello che ho appena detto però da 12 24
ma bene anche la vigilia era giusto tra
l'altro non ha neanche detto
però va bene non ho capito cosa ho fatto
neanche no non è vero l'ho capito che
sono una persona un po intelligente
quando mi impegno ad essere st
canzoncina per forza tutto il tempo come
c'è una fare aiuto devo creare la
triforza con la di zelda va bene non
credo di esserne in grado però ok
devo veramente creare la triforza amici
miei in matematica faccio pena però se
volete ci provo allora latte di forza da
quella facciamo così è bella triforza
che brutta mamma mia oh zitti zitti
zitti che sono fortissimo e cielo e da
vabbè questo faremo e giusto dai ragazzi
che un casino
fare e la triforza e che ci ho messo
un'ora per farla almeno ecco vedi questa
non è la giusta ci ho messo pure un'ora
di mortacci nier questo devo fare ma va
bene non l'avevo neanche visto che c'era
una stella o che è molto più c'è
ovviamente il tasto per chiamare
l'ascensore non l'avevo messo in conto
next che però qua c'è una luce a si
spegne a se si accenderà la luce si
accende proprio il fuoco va bè prendi
regali al buio attenzione un regalo mio
è una bomba non a chiave e sa quanta
roba ho trovato posto aggiornarci una
porta nascosta dietro let's go my
friends frigo vuoto
no tua sorella mamma mia e va beh sto
male
comunque niente male come di prima mi
sono piaciuto da solo è difficile che io
mi piaccia ma poi penso che io debba
comune con confluire confluisce re dalla
parte opposta non credo sia così
difficile però deve unire i neri a
sinistra ei verdi a destra non è una
questione di razzismo parca di una vacca
morta due giorni fa per ciò che macello
se di mamma mia che disastro
potevo farmi fare un altro gioco un po
più easy un po più nelle mie corde tipo
cooking mama
non so o tensione el'aveva macello no
vabbè ma impossibile da questo male o
che dovrei dovrei chi dovrei cambiare
questi due di posto per un macello che
non vi dico perché facile fare il cubo
di rubik rea demoni o morto no ma allora
ma allora le qualità le quali sono sei
anni in realtà però mi son dettagli
chissenefrega
sono proprio contento 5 come la stampata
che ti becchi in faccia io c'ho questo
pirulo che ho visto che ciò l'ho preso
prima
cos'è sta roba non ho ben capito ai
cinque mosse in cinque mosse dove
renderli tutti uguali va bene sei
veramente sicuro di questo
posso stupirti schiacciando a caso io
schiaccio spesso a caso le lamentele
schiaccia a caso e sbloccherò la porta
un giorno perché so di esserne in grado
vi racconto la storia della io da
piccolo ho scoperto che in realtà mio
zio era
natale è stata una cosa orribile ancora
adesso me lo sogno la notte anche perché
mio zio è una barba molto molto più
lunga di quella di kobo natale quindi
ogni volta che arrivava stato a tagliare
e nobile non mio zio la barba e sarà per
quello che non mi cresce con la in mezzo
fa questo è giusto e non si apre
se sì perché lavorare una difficile però
non si apre lo stesso ma guarda te la
vita che brutta il pulsante che pirla se
trovi utile gentle utile questo gioco è
utile te prego guarda te possino allora
solo raggiungere la vetta per far vedere
a youtube che forse il mio consentite
del tipo è molto più alto di quanto
pensano andando a caso ovviamente così
devo fare qua da white non ho capito
cosa devo fare
ho capito devo passare quelli blu a
destra con i rossi a sinistra visto che
bravo basta possiamo passare al brano
successivo era questo il quesito anno
dove anche farlo
vabbè allora no a easy faccio fatto con
oh sì yes
mamma mia mamma mia let's go my friends
con meno non solo di strada non mai
stack agata qua l sta per sinistra amsa
per su a ok devo trovare la via o che
doterà via perfetto easy cioè easy una
sega però right left left
mamma mia mamma mia
tutto qua tutto qua fare fermati a devo
creare due tra pezzi non ho capito a in
sei mosse sono fai sei mostre devo
creare due tra pezzi ok io non so
neanche cosa siano trapezio schiacciare
i tasti qua carino 1 2 3 4 5 e 6
non è giusto kakà ma noi dobbiamo fare
ok
dovevo o non dovevo fare questo dovremo
trasformare un tra piazza nella è un
trapezio presso un trapezista google e
al trapezio trapezio tra come sto bene
bravo non è un trapezio mai nel mondo è
un triangolo i soci
e qui la e qui social e un triangolo
equilatero ai rettangolo che pirla non
si può pensare rettangolo sorry sorry e
non andavo bene era un triangolo
rettangolo che se vi interessa al sicuro
next amici miei allora qua devo qua devo
scartavetrare la porta però non so come
a ecco c'è una porta che si chiude c'è
un regalo che devo sicuro c'è
mai impacchettato la porta in poche
parole come va come faccio a bot
non ho capito bomba bene era un pezzo
della scacchiera sto male quella fare lì
era un pezzo della scacchiera a devo
muovere cavalli in modo da sbloccarsi
tutte le cose ok pisi molto bene molto
bene molto bene molto bene
let's go a caso tra l'altro gli ultimi
due livelli di ho fatti totalmente
random anzi anche gli ultimi tre livelli
anche il triangolo non sapevo anche che
tipo di triangolo era allora 12 52 anche
qua devo scambiare sicuramente in 25
dicembre come lo scambio col martello
avevo scassare è successo a nova pesto
male e come faccio devo far uscire un
aiuto fermi si vabbè ma siamo veramente
un'infinità di tempo uno scherzo
schiacciavo va bene ho fatto cose molto
più difficile ai tempi va bene son
riuscito a incastrare non so come va
bene lesione sia uguale xvi hub ma non
posso sempre mettere 25 dicembre e frega
niente
come non so non ho idea di che calcolo
sia non posso mettere a caso 12 non è
sempre la stessa data no puoi farmi
questo regalo perché non li so fare i
calcoli di break 3 2
eccolo eccolo perché tutto qui perché ma
chi sei tu non le sai fare queste cose
ma cosa balli mamma mia
ero convinto delle mie idee sempre
convinti nelle vostre idee ragazzi se
due più due fa 6 fa 6 non fa altro che
sei next one
dovrebbe essere l'ultimo c'è ancora uno
dopo parka vacca
va beh devo evocare sauron non mi sembra
molto natalizia a parte la palla è
perfetto giusto giusto vuota man il vero
santa claus ed eroga with the ultimo
livello che forse il più difficile anzi
sicuramente devo far uscire il pezzo
grosso
il pezzo grosso sono io è questo è uno
dei più classici enigmi della storia
proprio non c'ero riuscito una volta
fare una roba del genere ma ci ho messo
tipo una vita ok a era lì il boom
immagine ma come come facevo a vederlo
mai nel mondo ma spiegami come quindi
era l'ultimo livello basta la pubblicità
a vasto stato molto figo molto quindi
ragazzi siamo
questa è la penultima torre dei cento
fiori poi abbiamo finito tutto 100 floor
tutto c'è un malato di mente sono stato
però spero vi siate divertiti
spero che non sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
e se vi piace tanto mi piace anche
questo secondo la descrizione sono
usciti iscrivete era ci vediamo siamo vi
prometto che non inizio con la intro di
hannah montana
[Musica]